on vous y invite cette semaine autour de
la machine à café de radio canada
international pour que vous répond dire
notre question tam-tam écoute on les
résultats sur facebook live vendredi à
11 heures
la question porte sur l'immigration bien
sûr un sujet brûlant d'actualité aux
états unis au canada aussi alors là il
ya beaucoup de pensée divergente au
canada par rapport à l'immigration ils
sont d'agen le swid en début de semaine
qui disait que le fort pourcentage de
canadiens et des contre l'immigration où
les niveaux de vibrations récent est
aussi vous avez un mouvement
probablement contradictoires celui des
grandes villes canadiennes beaucoup de
grandes villes canadiennes qui depuis
quelques jours ce départ vers sanctuaire
pour accueillir les réfugiés par exemple
des états unis alors d'autres questions
comme dame vous branchez de quel côté
côté wii ou du compte tenu du non au
niveau d'immigration au canada parce
qu'on devra faire plus soit faire moins
c'est à goutte de dire votre opinion